I can bring you an alarm or I can bring
you in cold
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Star Wars the Mandalorian
Episode one video so I'll break
everything down there was a whole bunch
of Easter eggs obviously it's just the
first episode they'll be eight this
season so if you're brand new to my
channel I'll be doing videos for all
them be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'll do a Star Wars giveaway for all the
videos - careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet but
we'll just do top 10 WTF and Easter eggs
as we go along so starting with number
10 the place in the setting in the time
period the series takes place five years
after Return of the Jedi mostly in the
Outer Rim territories we don't know
exactly where it takes place they
haven't said which planet's these are
but they'll be visiting a bunch of
different planets during the series for
the most part it seems like we're going
to new places that we haven't seen
before but with a lot of Easter eggs for
things from the classic trilogy from the
books from the expanded universe they're
recanted izing some things there's even
some stuff from the Star Wars Holiday
Special in here - as of right now the
Empire has already lost the battle of
jakku and what was left of their fleet
was taken by the Imperials that seized
command in the chaos there was a bit of
an imperial Civil War at jakku using
special maps from one of emperor
palpatine secret caches on jakku to plot
a course through the unknown regions
where they would eventually grow into
the first order but that didn't happen
until many years later so right now the
galaxy is still in chaos in the New
Republic has not been formed by the
rebellion yet so everybody is still
scrambling for power as you'll see over
the next couple of episodes not every
Imperial left to go form the first order
so there's still a lot of people that
are trying to maintain or restore what
power they had under imperial rule
number 9 meet the Mandalorian though so
you sort of get that intro with the
special musical cues just to let you
know what the series is going to be like
and what his character does it's sort of
a tutorial on the series in general this
opening scene in the cantina bit of a
callback to obi-wan throwing down in the
cantina and Star Wars a new hope to
opening with a scene of them doing
something really badass to let you know
how hardcore they are apparently the
Mandalorians name / Pedro Pascal is
denge aren but we don't know quite how
to spell that yet I haven't seen it
written only spoken Pedro Pascal did an
interview here where he revealed that
name there's a couple big
dregg's during this big cantina fight so
we get our first tutorial on best scar
steel best not scratch it because it's
almost priceless best car steel is the
special medal that Mandalorians used to
make all their weapons in their armor
it's way stronger than Duras steel which
is the most common type of metal used to
make ships and other weapons it's way
more resistant to blaster fire and it's
resistant to lightsabers they don't
mention the great Jedi war that the
Mandalorians had thousands of years ago
but as we go through this series I'll do
more relevant backstory on the
Mandalorian cultures history you notice
that the bartender slides him a
replacement drink on the house but it's
empty because the bartender knew that
the Mandalorian was going to beat the
crap out of those two dudes and wanted
to help him do it the one that's
spitting insults at the blue mithril is
actually speaking Huttese it's one of
the major languages of the criminal
underworld of the Star Wars galaxy the
blue mithril you may recognize as
horatio sanz from Saturday Night Live -
he was our first really big cameo in the
episode but number 8 beware the rabbinic
so this area is mostly covered in a
frozen ocean when he goes to secure the
taxi to get to his ship
the alien that helps him is a Kubas
first seen during episode 4 this speeder
that pulls up is a slightly modified
version of Luke Skywalker's land speeder
from episode 4 driven by an r2 unit but
he doesn't like droids then we get our
second big celebrity cameo its Brian
Posehn and driving the taxi may he rest
in peace he takes them to the
Mandalorian ship which is called the
razor crest it's a pre Empire patrol
ship modified to suit his bounty hunting
lifestyle but the Easter Egg for its
design is that it's actually based on
Jango Fett's ship from the video game
Star Wars bounty hunter that some of you
probably played but not before the
rabbinic eats Brian Posehn
and his land speeder in a very jaws
esque scene shark in the water it's a
brand new creature that they created for
the show but it's kind of like a rancor
crossed with a giant hippopotamus the
next big easter egg is actually for the
Star Wars Holiday Special
so his signature rifle with the dual
teeth at the end he uses to shock it
away his Boba Fett's rifle from the Star
Wars Holiday Special
that cartoon was also the very first
appearance of the Boba Fett character
and yes
Boba Fett did appear during this episode
when he's going to get his
skaar pauldron made by the smith in the
background he passes someone wearing
armor that looks identical to Boba
Fett's Green Mandalorian armor number
seven the Carbonite freezer obviously
big Easter egg for Empire Strikes Back
and Han Solo being frozen in carbonite
but the myth world tries to fake having
to go to the bathroom we see what is
probably our very first space toilet in
the Star Wars universe ever at least I'm
pretty sure when he accidentally opens
the weapons Locker
you also see Han Solo's blaster on the
wall when he's thumbing through the
Carbonite bounties you noticed that the
aliens are all major characters from the
original trilogy from Episode four to
Jabba's palace and Return of the Jedi
the first one is a Rodian r.i.p Greedo
you may have also seen yesterday there
was a bit of an internet controversy on
Disney Plus yesterday with the 4k
restoration version of a new hope number
six grave carga and the bounty hunters
guild so Carl Weathers plays the
administrator of the batty hunters guild
the guild itself was only created right
after the fall of the Empire so their
organization in the bounty Puck's that
they use all that stuff is only a couple
years old you get a shout out to Mon
Calamari Admiral Ackbar's homeworld we
get a reminder of the state of the
galaxy times are tough no one wants to
pay guild rates they give another
shout-out to Star Wars underworld during
their conversation which is actually a
shout-out to the original live-action
Star Wars TV series that Ronald D Moore
worked on they wrote 50 plus scripts but
then wound up scrapping the series at
the last minute before they started to
shoot it but then number 5 we learn
about the client so everyone probably
knows at least a little bit who Werner
Herzog is or you just remember his voice
from some project that he did you may
also remember him he did some Rick and
Morty during season 2 interdimensional
cable that was pretty funny
based on the necklace that he's wearing
in the episode it seems like he's a
former Imperial magistrate trying to
retain some power in the chaos in the
fact that he's commanding all these
stormtroopers he also has a very
official looking Imperial doctor working
for him the Droid that opens the door
for him is the same Droid managing the
gate at Jabba's palace and there's also
a gonk droid that walks him back through
the hallway they have their three-way
Mexican standoff moment and we get
another shout-out to best Skaar steel
and the bounty itself the amount of
money in best guard that he's offering
the Mandalorian
is actually priceless the magistrate
makes it very very clear that he wants
the bounty terminated but the doctor
insists that it be brought back alive
that's important for later that'll come
back around in a future episode but he
also lets us know what happened to the
Mandalorians under imperial rule
terrible what happened to your people
then later the Mandalorian armor when
she sees the best scar says this must
have been taken during the purge so it
sounds like the Empire stole all the
Mandalorians best scar and that's where
a lot of this best scars these being
offered as bounty came from number four
the weapon Smith and all the flashbacks
to the prequels so on the way to the
Smith you see a salacious crumb species
roasting on a spit and what in a cage
just meant to be a funny Easter Egg for
Return of the Jedi and then we see where
the local Mandalorian clan lives the
Mandalorian symbol above the forge is
actually designed to look like the skull
of the mythos or which Nick Nolte's
ignite bounty hunter mentions later in
the episode the mythos aura was a great
flying creature the size of a city that
lived on the Mandalorians previous
homeworld of Mandalore and was said to
have been conquered by the first person
to bear the name Mandalore when he says
to her that he does not have a signet
yet that's just an indication that he
hasn't been recognized as part of the
local Mandalorian clan or one of the
other clans it's a sign of membership
like you're not recognized as an
official Mandalorian unless you have a
signet which is one of the reasons why
Boba Fett was not a true Mandalorian
just someone who adopted Mandalorian
armor and weapons all the flashbacks are
to the Clone Wars so you have to picture
this happening somewhere around Star
Wars Episode two will probably get more
flashback scenes like this in future
episodes number three meet the ugh not
bounty hunter in the blogs so the blogs
are actually Easter eggs for the
made-for-tv Ewok Star Wars movies
caravan of courage and Ewoks battle for
Endor super deep cuts the ugh not bounty
hunter is played by Nick Nolte his voice
is very identifiable you'd recognize it
anywhere he mentions the great mythos or
like I said then we meet IG eleven
played by Ty Cobb YTD from thor ragnarok
he also probably recognized his voice he
said his character is meant to be kind
of like the Terminator inside the Star
Wars universe you kind of get a sense of
his personality during that introductory
shootout that he has number two shootout
at the
cake Corral very awesome classic
gunslingers shootout right out of a
spaghetti western they even have the
Star Wars equivalent of a giant Gatling
gun in blaster form the self-destruct
device that IG 11 keeps trying to use is
actually just a thermal detonator also
seen during Return of the Jedi in
Jabba's palace when Leia whipped it out
the number one WTF the bounty this was
such an awesome twist reveal they said
it was fifty years old
some species aged differently even if
you're not a big star Wars fan you
probably recognize it as a baby of
Yoda's species it's not Yoda just to be
clear because Yoda died during Return of
the Jedi that was about five years ago
so Yoda is a force ghost right now
laughing at the Mandalorian above
thanking him for helping this baby of
his species the reason why this is so
huge on the multiple levels is because
George Lucas made it so that virtually
nothing was known about Yoda's race we
do know a couple things about them other
than the fact that they're long-lived
they're very rare so members of his
species do exist throughout the galaxy
but there are only a couple of them at
any given time they have basic male and
female genders and they all live very
long lives and they're all very very
force sensitive yada Liz the only other
member of his species she's a female
that we saw during any Star Wars movies
any books or any comic books so it's
possible that Yoda could have mated with
her at some point in his 900 years my
other best theory is that is actually a
clone of Yoda because the doctor who was
asking it be brought back alive has the
same symbol on his sleeve as they did at
the cloning facility on Kamino during
episode two attack of the clones so let
me know in the comments do you think
that this is a clone of Yoda or do you
think that it's actually just another
baby of his species that's popped up but
now you see why the magistrate wanted
this baby terminated so badly because it
could grow up to be just as powerful a
Jedi Master is Yoda someday so a big
threat to the return of imperial rule
which is clearly what they want and then
we'll obviously see what happens through
the course of the series but a big part
of it will probably be him protecting
this baby from the Imperials it was a
great episode episode 2 is going to be
released on Friday so obviously my video
for that will post a little bit more
timely than this one did just because so
much is happening this week if you spot
any other really big Easter eggs in the
episode that I didn't mention in the
video just write them below in the
comments
everybody click here for my Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 1 video and
everyone click here for that Star Wars
mandalorian trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]